Well, can we, can we actually talk about the suffering? Sure.
The darkest parts of writing a book.
So the let's let's go to the full Michael moule, Stephen King mode of,
uh, one of the darkest moments of writing this book.
And what does it maybe start the white pill? What's the idea. What's the hope.
And what are your darkest moments around writing this book?
So people are familiar with the red pill and the blue pill. The,
the [inaudible] for the matrix,
the red pill is the idea that what is presented as fact by the corporate press
entertainment industry is in fact,
a carefully constructed narrative designed to keep some very unpleasant people
in power and everyone else under control.
And I guess one of my expressions is you take one red pill,
not the whole bottle. Yeah.
Because at a certain point you think everything's a lie and then you're,
you're kind of no capacity for distinguishing truth.
You're full good. One-liners well, thank you.
Yeah, I'm full of something. That's for sure.
And what I saw in this space is a lot of these
red pill, people got very, um,
disheartened and cynical.
And one of my big heroes is Albert Khumbu and he said,
the worst thing is citizens. And that's led something called the black pill,
which is the idea that, you know, it's, it's all it's, it's, it's just,
we're waiting for the end. It's hopeless.
And I don't see it that way at all. And I'm like,
all right, I have to address this.
And not just with some kind of cheerleading,
everything's going to be great guys. Here is why I am positive.
And not that I'm positive, the good guys you're going to win, but I'm positive.
The good guys can win.
And that's all you need because if your God forbid,
kid is kidnapped and there's a 10% chance that you can save them.
You're not going to be like, wow, I don't like those odds. This is your country.
This is your values. This is your family. Uh, I think it's a much more than 10%.
And even if you lose,
you will take pride in that you did everything in your power to win.
So is there a good.
Definition of good guys in the sense that once you wear white
there's layers to this you're like modern day Shakespeare.
Is there a danger in thinking, um, uh, at all,
Hitler was probably pretty confident that he
led a group of good guys.
Listen, if Hitler did anything wrong, why isn't he in jail?
A Czech friend thought of that.
He actually, he says that his accident goes in. It learns so bad.
Why isn't he in jail? Yeah, that's a good point.
He's probably still alive, right? Yeah. Hopefully.
Oh boy. Two of the three people listening to this are very upset, right?